the president who promised change is
demanding results by the end of this
week Saturday will be President Trump
100th day in office he is pushing
Congress for action on health care tax
reform and the border wall and one week
from today CBS this morning will come to
you from the White House we will all be
there next Monday with a special
broadcast it will include part of John
Dickerson's interview with the President
on his 100th day in office for Face the
Nation that's this coming Sunday looking
forward to that a new poll this morning
though shows fifty three percent of
americans disapprove of the job
President Trump is doing only forty-two
percent approved that is the lowest
approval rating of any president at this
point in his term since President Truman
back in nineteen forty five fifty six
percent say the president has
accomplished little or nothing so far
Margaret Brennan is at the White House
Margaret good morning good morning while
president Trump now says the 100-day
mark is not very meaningful but he's
still trying to jam through a series of
major initiatives this week to meet the
100-day deadline he set for himself
during the campaign and vice president
Mike Pence is returning a day early from
Asia to help him no particular rush but
we'll see what happens the president is
publicly downplaying the urgency but
behind the scenes the White House is
pushing Republican Speaker Paul Ryan to
try again to repeal and replace
Obamacare but so far there is no bill
ready and no vote scheduled to consider
it and we'll be having a big
announcement on Wednesday the president
also wants to unveil tax reform saying
his overhaul plan would be quote bigger
than any tax cut ever but on Sunday his
OMB director Mick Mulvaney lowered
expectations can either have a small tax
cut that's permanent or a large tax cut
that a short-term I don't think we
decided yet mr. Trump has not delivered
on other signature issues a federal
court judge suspended his travel ban on
six muslim-majority countries and he
backtracked on a vow to brand China a
currency manipulator no administration
has accomplished more in the first 90
days but mr. Trump has ticked through a
number of items like appointing a
Supreme Court justice with
all from the trans-pacific trade deal
and green lighting the Keystone pipeline
however the federal government could
come to a grinding halt by Friday
without a new spending bill to fund it
passage may hinge on whether mr. Trump
insists on his long promised border wall
well we're going to get paid for one way
or the other on Sunday Attorney General
Jeff Sessions suggested funding it by
eliminating tax credits that he claimed
benefited Mexicans illegally in the US I
know there's four billion dollars a year
in excess payments that are going to pay
much to people tax credits that they
shouldn't get these are mostly Mexicans
and those kind of things add up now that
claim may be based on the 2011 report by
the Treasury Inspector General that
showed individuals who aren't legally
authorized to work in the US did receive
tax credits but the report did not say
the individuals are Mexicans Nora it
appears US taxpayers not Mexico will pay
for that wall all right Margaret thank
you